The term quantum teleportation may sound like the stuff of science fiction, but as we'll talk about in today's episode
of Kiskit in the Classroom, it's a very real and very useful technique for quantum communication and
networking. Welcome to Qiskit in the classroom. In the series, we'll use Qiskit to explore some fundamental
concepts commonly covered in quantum computing related courses. Each video is accompanied by an interactive module
linked in the description below, so be sure to check it out. Teleportation is kind of a science fiction and fantasy
trope at this point. A person or object disappears from one location and instantaneously appears somewhere else.
As cool as this would be, unfortunately, this kind of teleportation at least is impossible. It would break the cosmic
speed limit. Nothing can travel faster than light. But quantum teleportation is
possible. In quantum teleportation, information rather than matter can be transmitted between two
distant locations. All you need is a pair of entangled particles, one at each site, and a way to communicate classical
information between the two sites. This protocol was developed in 1993 by a team
of quantum scientists, including IBM's Charles Bennett. They called it quantum teleportation because similar to the
science fiction version, the quantum information disappeared from one location and appeared in another distant
location without ever traveling through the intervening space. It may sound like magic, but as we'll see, there's nothing
mysterious or magic about it. It's enabled by the phenomenon of quantum entanglement along with classical
communication. Today we're going to walk through the quantum teleportation protocol and how it works. And then we'll put it into
action on a real quantum computer to teleport the state of a cubit from one side of an IBM quantum processor to
another. So here's how a quantum teleportation works. Suppose we have two people Alice and Bob who are separated
by a large distance. Say Alice has a cubit. We'll call cubit Q just for convenience. And it's in some
unknown quantum state sq where alpha 0 and alpha 1 are complex
numbers. Alice wants to send her state to Bob, but she has no way to actually send the cubit itself. It could be that
he's too far away, or maybe she doesn't even know exactly where Bob is, so she doesn't know where to send it. Luckily,
the friends already share a pair of entangled cubits A and B, where Alice has cubit A and Bob has cubit B. And
these cubits are entangled. By entangled, I mean that even though the two cubits are separated by a large
distance, their states are correlated in a way that classical physics cannot account for. This entangled pair is
something called an Ebit, which we can use as a resource in quantum computing and communication.
In this case, Alice can use the EBIT as a resource to transmit her quantum information to Bob. To see how, let's
start by writing out the joint state of all three of these cubits where I've ordered the cubits somewhat arbitrarily
at this point, but this ordering will be convenient when we run our experiment on Kiskit. In Qiskit, the standard way to
order the cubits is right to left. So, the state of cubit zero will appear on the right.
Let's expand the state a little bit and rewrite it like this. Then the first step in our teleportation protocol is
for Alice to entangle her data cubit with her half of the EBIT cubit using a C knot gate. A C knot or controlled KN
gate will change the state of one cubit, the target cubit, depending on the state of another cubit, the control cubit.
If the control cubit is in the state zero, then nothing happens to the target. And if the control cubit's in
the state one, then the target cubit is flipped. So in this case, Alice's data cubit Q will be the control cubit and
her Ebit cubit A will be the target cubit. So the first two terms didn't change at all by the C knot, but the
last two terms did because the control cubit Q was in the state one. Then Alice
would apply a hatamard gate to her data cubit Q which takes the state 0 to the state 1 /2 0 + 1 and the state 1 to
1 over 2 0 -1. I'm going to skip some simple algebra here which you can try to fill in on your own if you want.
But after rearranging some terms you'll get a state that looks like this. So now Alice and Bob's three cubit
entangled state looks like a complete mess. But look what happens if Alice measures both her cubits. The three
cubit state will partially collapse to one of these four
terms. And in each case, Bob will be left with a superposition state with amplitudes that are related to Alice's
initial unknown state. Remember the amplitudes are alpha 0 and alpha 1. So
for example, if Alice measures both cubits to be zero, then Bob's state will collapse to this term, the original
unknown state that Alice wanted to teleport. But if Alice measures zero on cubit A and one on cubit Q, then Bob's
state will be this one. This state can be transformed into the original state of cubit Q if Bob
applies a Zgate, which will flip this sign here. But Bob won't know to do this
until he learns what Alice has measured. So the next step in the protocol is for Alice to call up Bob and tell him what
her two measurements were. After he knows that, he'll know what operations to perform on his cubit to make it match
Alice's original state. Here's a table of the four possible measurements and the four possible operations that Bob
will need to perform on his cubit based on those measurements. Bob might need to perform a Zgate, an Xgate, or both to
transform his cubit to match Alice's original cubit. This last step, where Alice calls Bob, by the way, is why
quantum teleportation doesn't violate causality. Even though Bob's state instantly collapsed when Alice measured
her cubits, Bob couldn't get any information out of that state until Alice told Bob what she measured. And
that call was limited by the speed of light. We just went through a lot of detailed math, so the incredible fact
that we just teleported quantum information may have gotten lost. But it's really pretty amazing. By using
entanglement as a resource, Alice could make a measurement to destroy quantum information stored with her and have it
appear in another distant location with Bob. This distance could be hundreds, even thousands of kilometers. Even more
amazingly, this protocol doesn't even require that Alice know exactly where Bob is. As long as they share an Ebit
and they can classically communicate with one another, quantum teleportation will work. Now, let's see how this works